hello hola um
first of all huge congratulations i
adore the project i beat you only one
city which probably
was a bit too much to handle but um
i want to ask first of all when you
first uh talk to her about the project
and you started reading the script
what spoke to you the most about maya
um i
i love the muscle american influences
the inspiration that he took from his
and from from his heritage um with it
with the dazzle of caribbean culture
which obviously i'm very much
you know
happy about that um i also like that at
the helm was this young bright 15 year
old girl that was feisty and knew
exactly who she was and was was pushing
up against sort of like the traditional
roles that she was being subjected to
fulfill
um and that to me felt just relatable um
absolutely necessary but also like you
know aside from any kind of like social
justice
kind of commentary representation
um it's it's it just feels good it feels
good like i'm i just i i'm a quiet
uh proud latinx you know american
um who lives
my
my culture and everything that i do
every single day so i don't know how to
talk about it as much as i know how to
live it you know
so getting to see that and getting to
share that is beautiful and makes me
really happy
um do you
what sort of influences or inspiration
do you draw for your performance
well it's very similar to jorge who took
inspiration as he was conceiving maya
from his wife and his mother and his
sister like all these brave and awesome
women in his life i i mean
pick a corner in my life i come from a
family of matriarchs and i'm one of
three sisters i just lost my grandmother
two years ago but she was
everything to us and um my mother
is the most fantastic person i've ever
met so i i i i took inspiration not just
from like immediate family but also
from friends and colleagues and
neighbors
that every time i see you know a little
spunk that reminds me that oh there's
there's some latin blood in there
these are the people that i sort of
channel all the time you know whenever i
do the characters that require that
um
how do you approach uh
voicing a character like maya compared
to when you do live action but is there
any
uh particular differences in the way you
approach a character when in
animation
well for me at least personally i tend
to be a lot more relaxed uh when it's
animation and i'm just voicing it
because
i
the the the focus is more on this than
the spiritual and sort of like internal
connection to this character so that
your voice can just be that instrument
but obviously when you do live action
there's just a lot more components that
you always have to think about um so you
do have that freedom you can roll in in
your pjs and just do a five hour session
and nobody judges you nobody goes is she
okay
you don't have to go through hair and
makeup you just have to go through
endless conversations with a very
generous director like jorge gutierrez
will immediately just like place you in
that time and the moment of something
and
and then just you interact with him it's
it's it's actually a wonderful
experience
there's a lot of physicality to the to
to maya and and a lot of action in the
in in the project how
um do you try to address that in your in
your in the recording booth do you do
anything to to sort of get into the
character like that
you try but remember too like when if
you do any kind of like abrupt movements
then the microphone picks it up
so it all has to be practiced and first
and then when they are rolling it just
has to be interpreted through the voice
so it it it does come with its sets of
challenges when you do
you only lend your voice as the only
instrument of interpretation
um
but it's fun it's a lot of fun
um
you you have played a lot of uh badass
female warriors in in in tv and film um
what what makes maya different than some
of the other characters that you have
played
she's 15.
[Music]
um and i feel like she's a lot more
stubborn than many other characters i've
played before
but
i do like i gravitate towards characters
i guess that
that maybe maybe i am you know and i'm
just unaware of it you know i've been
i've been told that i'm i can be a very
guarded person you know it takes a while
for me to sort of
warm up and feel safe around certain
like i guess it's just social anxiety so
i tend to gravitate towards
um characters that
that you know i maybe i see myself in
them but i but also i i don't approach
them because of their strength and their
and their walls i that's not what gets
me excited about them what gets me
excited about them are their struggles
their inner struggles and um
and their weaknesses and their flaws and
their fears and their stakes like you
know all of these things because it's so
it's um
it's it's very easy to look at a woman
and just because she knows what she
wants that that that that she's strong
and you and you just write her off for
just that title but
there's so many layers to to a person
you know there's a lot of fragility that
sometimes a strong person is protecting
i feel like
maya is like that she's she's protecting
her freedom you know she wants to be
free to be whoever she wants to be and
in that she's willing to fight you know
and and but then when that freedom
becomes not just a personal goal but
the goal of her kingdom and her people's
freedom is relying on her
um
she's reminded that she's just 15 and
she's scared and she's vulnerable and
she's insecure and then through the help
of her friends
she she grows all of these all of these
strengths you know and so i i really
like what what uh what jorge put
together he really created a wholesome
young woman
also thank you so much pleasure talking
to you huge congratulations on my ex i
love you
okay